and one hopes it was practicality that
drove them to have the asylum seekers
where these wristbands but I think we
should go back a step I mean
notwithstanding anybody was wearing a
wristband or when we looked at what was
happening in Middlesbrough a similar
type case slightly different situation
though the idea that if you're wearing a
wristband or if your door is painted a
particular color that that should invite
abuse hatred is ugly our poor a'n't and
if we consider the history of our
country our grandparents force against
the kind of ideology in the 1930s that
suggested it was okay to other people
that it was okay to escape goat
different groups of people in our
society they fought and died for that
and yet some people think that Minority
mind you that that is justified in 20 70
2016 that is an utter disgrace so we've
got to send out a very clear message the
however people are identified the fact
that there are an asylum seeker seeking
refuge in our country does not justify
the kind of abuse that they've received
and anybody watching this program who's
dishing out that kind of thing to people
they need to know that is terribly
terribly unwritten so you're more
concerned about that the public reaction
to the wristbands than actually the
company that came up with the risk well
it's the minority and we've got to send
a clear message to that minority and I
think we should celebrate the fact that
when these things have come to light
wristbands are the latest there has been
a huge well of concern for what's been
happening because we don't think that's
what we're about as a country but you
have to ask the question and I sit on
the Home Affairs Select Committee will
be taking evidence from g4s and Joe mass
that were the company involved in the
acute you know alleged painting of
people's doors if they're the red doors
last week we'll be taking evidence from
them tomorrow afternoon we have to ask
the question the Home Office of the ones
who put out these contracts what are
they doing to monitor the way that these
contracts are implemented is this a
problem when you outsource sensitive
areas of policy to private companies who
aren't necessary
thinking about the political and the
ethical ramifications well I think
there's definitely an issue here that
where is the oversight of this but I
think there's a bigger issue to actually
I think from the point of view of the
asylum seekers and you read the
testimony of them in the garden I think
unveiled this this latest story what
they want to do is they want to feel
part of our community they want to
integrate and you know having somebody
wear a wristband which you know enables
people to single them out hardly helps
them integrate and let's be honest about
it these issues of people claiming
asylum refugees get intermingled with
the general issues of migration and
immigration which have become such a
toxic debate unfortunately in our
country now I think the way we detoxify
that is ensuring that when people do
come here that they are able and
assisted to integrate into society
because it's through knowing each other
that you break down those barriers you
break down the prejudice that sometimes
there is in society even in 2016 on the
subject of refugees I wanted to ask you
about the calls this weekend for Britain
to admit 3,000 unaccompanied child
refugees and how does that work in
practical terms because the support
systems need to be there don't they and
there are councils that are saying we
just cannot cope well I think there are
real issues of capacity I think
absolutely we should do everything that
we can to accommodate particularly the
children but I think ultimately what
this illustrates is first of all we need
an overall EU framework there was an
agreement whereby various different
countries were going to take refugees
and there was a quote for each of the
countries we didn't fall within the
quota system but that was fo supposed to
oversee thousands of refugees coming to
Europe and you know it simply hasn't
worked thus far and we can only deal
with this on a cross-border level and we
need to make that EU framework work
secondly there needs to be a deal done
with Turkey and there are ongoing issues
there i think the EU is providing 2.2
billion pounds worth of support to
Turkey to deal with the refugees coming
through their borders they say that's
not enough but there has to be an
agreement reached Jack romina thank you
very much indeed thank you